the jurogan experience when you know
like the wave is about to collapse on
you like what do you do
i mean you just
you just uh you execute your plan that
you that you that you have um
like for me it was more and i don't do
as much big wave stuff as i once did i'm
49 now and trying to mellow out i still
love big waves but but it was my life
for a while and and at the time i was
training like a madman like super
physically fit working out six days a
week super high like crazy intense
um and i was working with like breath
coaches to do like breath work and stuff
so as soon as i would paddle into the
lineup when i was surfing big waves i
was breathing to where i was oxygenating
my oxygenating my lungs did i say that
right
and so
um
you basically try to get as much air
into your lungs as possible when you
know you're about to eat [ __ ] or go
under a really huge wave and then you're
it's just a matter of like holding your
breath so you just take a giant deep
breath right yeah
like crazy and you stuff your lungs and
everywhere else as much as you can you
pack your lungs with as much air as much
oh my god shane dorian what the [ __ ]
jesus christ that's scary and that's me
eating [ __ ]
wow but look at this
oh my god that's so wild dude and when
you eat [ __ ] that hard
and it comes down you that hard like
how much time
does it take before you can get up to
the surface it really depends i mean in
a really bad situation i had one
i had one wipeout uh off the coast of
northern california and half moon bay at
this wave called mavericks where
this chick was on a boat filming and she
filmed me eating [ __ ] much like that
and i was underwater she was filming my
board and it was tombstoning meaning she
could only see the top half of my
surfboard the bottom half was underwater
and i was at the i was the at the end of
like a 15 foot leash to my surfboard so
my board is about 10 and a half feet
long my leash was 15 feet long and then
i was
at the very bottom of that leash and i
was under water for a minute and about
eight seconds
a long time it doesn't sound like that
long right [ __ ] sounds like a long
ass time but i did a lot of breath
training or didn't do a lot of breath
training but i did some breath training
and and like
basically your static breath hold like
whatever you can do in a pool with a
calm heart rate
like
you can basically under pressure like if
your heart rate's going crazy you can
you can hold your breath for a quarter
of your static breath oh my god so like
when i do my static wait when i yeah
isn't that scary
terrifying but it's powerful because
if you know that you have say
hypothetically you have a four minute
breath hold static
then that means under pressure like in a
situation like that where your heart
rate's really high and you're getting
the [ __ ] kicked out of you you should be
able to hold your breath for one minute
and survive yeah but i don't i can't
hold my breath for four minutes i think
when we did that thing with uh how long
did they blame it how long did their
homework we didn't finish it but you did
it for quite a long time and he was
about to teach us how to do it longer
but we didn't get that far
they can teach you well i did it longer
than everybody else but i still didn't
think it was that long
over two minutes i think yeah but that's
not that but i don't think it was four
yeah yeah i think it was like two and a
half minutes but vasila lomachenko one
of the things he does for every fight is
he tries to make his ability to hold his
breath longer and for this last one he
got to four minutes and 30 seconds which
is like two seconds longer than it is
the rookie numbers
that would imagine for like a free
server or a free documentary it's got to
be so good for him right it's a huge
advantage that lung capacity is is
massive with fighting yes for sure but i
mean i think he does it also just for
mental toughness just like to build just
the ability to steal his mind and just
[ __ ]
just a lot of it is just being like for
me it was great because i had that like
if if you don't know that if you don't
know the science behind holding your
breath for a long time under pressure
with a high heart rate then you just go
into these wipeouts like [ __ ] i hope i
survive i need to hold my breath and
when you have that hope type of mindset
then your heart rate goes higher and you
start burning more oxygen right but if
you don't have that hope if that's not a
part of your mindset and you're just
like [ __ ] i've done the training i know
how long i can hold my breath with a
high heart rate and and knowing that
that number and knowing that you're
pretty much never going to be held under
water for that long like i could hold my
breath
the longest i held my breath during this
during the the
during the breath training thing that i
did was
five minutes and 34 seconds well hope is
not a good thing for any skill no like i
hope the ball goes in the net it's not
going in i hope i make this shot i'm not
making the shot like an archery like you
can't hope you hit the vitals you have
to know you're gonna hit the vitals when
you release that arrow that arrow you
have to have [ __ ]
hours and hours and hours right hours
and hours of training if you're hoping
yeah you're hoping you're [ __ ] yeah
you're [ __ ] and it's like that with
big waves so for me i was like hey i can
hold my breath for five minutes and 34
seconds and so i can so so 25 of that i
can do that with a high heart rate so
that's your your record it's 5 30 four
yeah
when those free divers get to like seven
eight minutes like what are they doing
different they just well and i i only
did one three day course of like breath
training or for four day course so they
so they teach you the science behind
breath holding and they they they help
you with like things to think about to
get your static higher and higher and
higher give us the cliff notes like what
are they
essentially um
they
they have you hold your breath right to
start see how you know what your static
breath hold is and then they teach you
how to how to hold it for longer and so
it's almost like meditation like for me
like the um
you basically think of you don't think
of time you don't count the seconds you
think about things that have like like
for me it was like they were like okay
think about something that's super
detailed and go through that process
while you're holding your breath so i
was in the pool and a guy's timing me
and i'm in a wetsuit and i go underwater
and i packed my bags to go hunting on
lanai oh yeah so i was like hey
i
so i started holding my breath i went
underwater and i was like hey what do i
need for my hunting trip on lanai i need
i need how many arrows do i need
three dozen
[Laughter]
and then i was like okay get my broad
heads then i gotta get my my boots okay
now i gotta get my waterproof boots i
need to get my like sneaking shoes okay
what socks do i need like a super
detailed
super boring stuff that you know really
well and i went through that whole
packing thing and then i like literally
i got in my truck in my mind drove down
to the airport
got on the plane flew there got off the
plane it was like all this stuff was
happening and then i didn't know how
much time it passed and then after and
then you know you have that involuntary
uh urge to breathe you know have you
ever held your breath for a long time
and all of a sudden you go
yeah your stomach starts doing this
thing and it's like telling your brain
you need to breathe now or else you're
going to die but it's not true
so
when you do these breath holding classes
it's really neat because they tell you
like when that urge to breathe that
tells you you need to be right now or
you're going to blackout or die or
whatever it is especially if you're
underwater it's really scary right and
so
they teach you to go okay you need to
hold through these these these uh these
big contractions and so like these
contractions are are happening and
you're not paying attention to them when
you're like in this meditative type of
mindset and that's how you can hold your
breath for a super long time so when you
go through them
does it ever get easier when you're you
hit those things yeah it's just
something you learn how to deal with
it's super uncomfortable right and so
yeah you learn to deal with it you learn
to go okay this is totally normal i know
i can hold through multiple minutes of
this this these contracts this urge yeah
so then you end up like not even paying
attention to them really yeah
so but you need to at the end because
you get really like spacey and relaxed
like like super in this meditative state
to where like at the end because they
start speeding up those contractions
start speeding up and when they get to a
certain when they get to a certain um
you know when they start happening fast
enough you black out
so when i was doing this this this
underwater training you know you do it
with a partner there's a guy watching
you all the time so you don't have a
shallow water blackout and you don't
drown jesus yeah